so today I'm going to tell you a little
bit about my latest work sometimes my
piece is working also some of the kind
of work that I like to pursue in the
next few years so specifically I will
tell you about how to combine research
from data mining to area data mining and
human come to interaction to help people
make sense of large graph so a large
data etc graph
so naturally I work with large graphs so
what is that some people call it large
large network data so what is that then
here are some examples for you
so for the internet you can consider or
viewed it as a a large graph of 50
billion web pages so it should know in
the in the graph would be a web page and
then a link or web link would be a link
in the in the graph and the Facebook so
I need to keep updating this page so now
you can think of it as a 1 billion node
graph where the the note in the graph is
a user and then an edge would be a
friendship right and you can in academia
you can have these large graphs I'm
sorry
constructed from a paper so H no in the
ground would be a paper and then an
attribute citation edge right so they're
actually a lot more examples like that
you can conserve all those whom graph
from Twitter Amazon you can construct a
who buys what graph so each note would
either be a person or product in the
graph and of course like cell phone
network will cost whom and in biology
you can figure out how protein and
protein interact with each other so
there many many more examples and this
graphs are not only getting bigger there
are also there many more of them these
days and they provide us with new
opportunities to understand a lot more
things like how people interact if you
look at the Twitter ground you hit the
facebook graph you can understand the
people's purchasing behavior you look at
the Amazon graph like what's a buying
train and also have a through prevent
diseases for example if we know how
proteins interact then well we can
develop new drugs target specific a
property so here's some of the example
large graphs that I personally
personally analyze so notice that there
the order a million a billion of no
sententious at least and the largest one
is the second one so the first one is is
whether we call the Yahoo web Grasso is
a snapshot of the web so it's note would
be a web page and a link will get wet
lane so it's a little bit old we are
around 2002 so that's why you only have
one point four billion Azure web pages
and six billion edges and the second one
which is the largest is a graph from
Symantec that company that develops our
Norton AntiVirus and I will tell you a
lot more about that and in a few minutes
so then in this crowd there are over
thirty seven billion edges so the note
in this graphs are either a machine or a
file and a file with those two notes
will be linked together if the file
appear on the machine so that's a
bipartite graph acquired technically
because there are two types of notes and
there are links between the two type and
not within the time so having all these
big data beta Gators that you will say
well that's great right so a lot of
students he's a lot of great things that
you can do but are there also challenges
too so if I asked you that question then
the answer would be yes and I would
argue that a lot of the challenges come
from due to one single number number
seven so this might be a good audience
to ask because allow do you have HCI
background so anyone can tell you why
that might be a challenge in dealing
with big data set yes
yes keep decreasing so it's a very
famous Millis law so it is basically no
I found out that well on an effort human
they probably only carry a very few a
process very few number of things at a
time and it's the working memory so
seven plus or minus two so for me I
think now it's maybe three or four and
something like that so what that really
means is that even if you have all these
big amount of data like billions and
billions trillions a record what you
really want to do is to help people
distill the essence out of it so in
other words you want to transform this
big data set into insights right so it's
really hard to do so how do we do it and
and what do we need so this is what what
I want you to get some idea out of the
raw through my talk today and my Civic
approach is to combine research from two
area data mining and human-computer
interaction to take techniques from both
areas combine them to help people do
that and actually each area individually
they have already been working for a
long time on developing methods to help
you make sense of data but their
approaches are very different from the
data mining side is focused on automatic
methods like summarization clustering
classification and so on and these
methods are quite quite scalable so a
lot of them naturally very easily scales
to millions of billions of notes and
hatches welcome the HCI side we've
looked at a problem from a slightly
different perspective so look at these
user driven iterative approaches which
take into account not only the task but
also the goals of the user and some
techniques generally fall into our
interaction visualization and so on and
these methods because they are
inherently like menu and human driven so
they are less scalable and they send
scale to maybe thousands or tens of
thousands of notes and edges so you may
ask so well two areas have long been
working on it and that problem so why do
they need each other right so here is a
simplified example so suppose you're
working at a cell phone company and your
boss tell you that hey so
we have all the data collected from our
customers so it's you know in the ground
would be as customer and then an ant
would be a phone call so you're gonna be
like right out of it and say well so if
I know something of business value
Oliver you have no idea what that means
what does it what am I looking for
so one good way to start typically is to
say well let's try visualizing and data
since we don't really know what we're
looking for to some exploratory kind of
analysis but if you try to visualize
like a million billion no ground you
would get something like this very very
pretty but then you don't really know
where to to conics so if you can get
some help from data mining algorithm for
example you can say use an anomaly
detection based algorithm then they can
help you pick out something that
probably are outlier so where are things
that you don't really expect from the
ground so and you were all great so this
could be my my starting point right and
some algorithms are even better if they
will tell you we rang all these
anomalies for you they'll give you a
score so the first one is most anomalous
second ones less so and so on so it'll
be a long list and a lot of the
algorithm they will stop there right
there that gives you the list they give
you the scores and that's it they don't
really they tell you what but then
though they don't really tell you why so
why are these highly ranked so at this
time if you are able to use some of the
techniques from the human-computer
interaction say I try to visualize the
connection between the the fourth so I'm
simplifying here because exactly the
determinant in what visualization
techniques to use as a challenge suppose
you can easily just visualize it Big O
effective way then you may see the first
four actually form a clique so the
larger clique in the network the more
suspicious it is so in a cellphone
Network what that means is you have this
whole group of people who know each
other so not very typical so through
visualization you can find out
understand about that and also if you
provide a right interaction technique
for the user to expand on these at this
node then they find out that the last
one the fifth one may actually
correspond to the center of the star so
here each node is a customer right so at
the center of the star could mean as a
is a may be a telemarketer right so we
mix a lot of call to different people
but those people don't know each other
so again that's another type of and
well you can but there are techniques
that were originally designed for scale
for small scale so start with small
scale that may not be able to scale to
to large data so for example just take a
simple example of visualizing just all
out that it's not that you cannot do it
you probably can't do it but you powe
don't want to do it right so that
similarly for interaction to so you
might want to you may be able to
interact with things but then you may
things my slow down or your part
wouldn't be able to understand that
whole range so relying on people to
manually pick things out maybe you can
provide some computation support so
that's that so that's really that's the
kind of my main message is to say well
so can we kind of take techniques from
each each side and then combine them so
that they can help each other
so basically bridging the to two areas
and developing methods that can combine
the best of both worlds so this is a
very quick overview of my talk through
my PhD and so I build up quite a few a
system systems and some in the data
mining area some in the human-computer
interaction area and some of them are
into intersection of them so for this
talk I will focus on three pieces of
work to in the data mining area and one
in the intersection so polonium is a
system that does malware detection over
37 billion edge graph net proto is
another system that does fraud detection
on eBay so these two are purely data
mining but you know explain briefly that
why why these technique would be useful
for HCI and Apolo is a system for the
network exploring Network large network
so is use this machine learning
in the background which visualizing an
interaction on foreground so combining
these two to help people explore network
so these are the three systems that I
will focus on and specifically I will
divide these systems into three well
divided my talk into three three groups
and put polonium and a probe into the
first part of my talk which I would call
attention routing so what does mean what
do I mean by that so I'm hoping to show
you that using these data mining
techniques I can we can help people to
figure out what at a good starting point
for them to start the analysis with so
essentially you want to route people's
attention through this whole big data to
specific point in the data set so route
the attention to a specific point and
then for the second part of my talk we
argue that well just having these data
money high with them is not enough
because they make mistakes right so and
then also different people have
different preference in what they want
to look at so it's useful to have use
users feedback into the data mining
process to guide the algorithm so to the
algorithm and the user work together so
I will talk about the a polar system
which is a mixin initiative combining
machine learning and visualization and
then in the end I will talk about the
kind of work that I find really excited
that I like to work on that I see also
there's a lot more research these days
on so I think those are good direction
in this area so I'll start with the
first system polonium so it's published
in the SDM 2011 a top data mining
conference so to help you understand the
contributions of polonium I'm going to
quickly tell you what existing
technology malware detection is so it's
based on what we call signature based
detection so meaning that malware
software company say cement and McAfee
they were try to generate a signature
for each piece of malware that they know
law and then they would distribute all
these signatures to the user as updates
that's why you get a lot of updates from
them and then your computer was scan
yeah this computer with scan for files
that match so signature and well there's
a problem with that
so the signatures have created a lot of
times on human so that means if
no signature generator in time you
cannot do the detection so how do we
have a more scalable way of generating
this ticket signature in more I love or
how do we determine whether a file is a
good or bad without relying on a lot
these signature so that's where the
Samantha's new approach called
reputation based detection approach
comes into play so they are trying to
compute what we call a reputation score
for each application in the whole planet
so the idea is to say well if we can
find our reputation or file then we can
say what is good or bad
so low reputation poor reputation means
of malware good reputation is a good
software so I'll tell you in a second
what that means by how to compute the
reputation score per suppose you do have
that then you could do this a
classification and so Polonius one
example technologies has space on this
reputation based approach so it computes
a reputation score for each application
and it's now pet in it
I'm not patent-pending anymore it's a
work that I that is design and
development as an intern several years
ago and they were really happy that with
the initial details and they are now
deployed Pullum is now deployed in all
the latest noted antivirus software and
has now store over 120 million users
worldwide and answer over trillions of
queries for reputation and so that means
you're using the latest not an average
antivirus software you'll be using a
piece of polonium or actually a piece of
me because I named it after myself
so it has polo in it yes so it's the
best time to name a system after
yourself when you're a grad student
because you create it so and it's not my
name you know they also describe this
day how the technology works so the fool
and for its propagation of leverage of
network influence and earth malware so
the key is network influence so in a few
slides down you understand what it means
so it's the key concept that we use to
label these files into good or bad
so I start with a little bit about the
data that polonium works right so a few
years back that the data was about 60
terabytes and it's collected from over
15 million machines who that anomalous
anonymously reported about their
executable files and they're over 900
million files total each one uniquely
identified by its cryptographic hash
value and the goal is very simple we
want to determine where that file is
good or bad right good or nowhere so you
ask so it seems like a classic
classification problem so why is that
hard so there's three reasons for it so
the first reason is that now we're
dealing with a much bigger data set so
that means algorithms methods that work
well for small data that may not
necessarily work a large data so first
one is size second one is here we wanted
to detect all kinds of malware that
cemento is already flagging not specific
type so that means you verify technique
that we really want well for one time we
may not work well for others so here we
want a pretty general method that can
detect all types of malware and the
third reason is that we want a false
alarm rate to be really low so false
alarm meaning you mistakenly classify a
good file as fat so say Microsoft Word
ax e if you classify an S bad that's
disastrous because they affect millions
and millions of people in the world so
we want the false alarm rate to be
really really low so for all these
reasons they become a tough problem so
how do we deal with it
so one way to think about it is to well
treat every files as individual records
and ignoring all the other information
which we we thought was very useful so
what we did instead is with take into
account the code the relationship
between the files and the machines that
those files appear on so specifically
what we did is converting the data into
a bipartite graph so a node say this
node if it's reported by two machines
then it will be and there will be an
edge linking from this vile to this
machine in this file is this machine so
because my part our graph bipartite
because they're two types
those files and machines and there's no
answers between each type of death there
are answers between the two type and
after this this transformation that this
graph has about thirty seven billion
edges and 1 billion notes the no sight
either machines or files and samantha
already know some information about the
file so they know some of them are do is
some of them are bad and the goal is
still the same right we want to find out
about the question mark file so whether
they're good or bad all right so that's
the formal program definition so a
little bit about the information that
semantic does her so they know some
files are good some are bad so they call
that known good and known bad files and
they put it in a ground truth database
so how we might use this known good on
that information is we can say well poor
not a file that we know it's known good
then we can say its prior probability of
being good or appropriate information
without doing and really anything is
it's close to 1 or 0.9 so if we map it
to a popular probability value then 0
would mean really bad one is likely to
be very good 0.5 you can fit s unknown
so and then there is some other things
so say they they might have a rough idea
about where that machine is maybe
careless or not so say if a machine
doesn't really run updates or get the
latest of data is probably a careless
machine then again you can map this
carelessness to say a score between 0
and 1 0 means careless one means careful
right so so that means they do know a
little bit about some file they know a
little bit about some machine may not be
accurate but they do know a little bit
about it so the idea now is so what can
we use all this known information about
the files and machines and use it to
somehow transfer that to the unknown
file here so how do we infer whether
this is a good fire or not right and the
key idea that we used is what we've got
guilt by association so what they really
mean is that things are similar are
likely to be connected in the network so
that means if I'm guilty for something
and if I know you then your policy also
guilty so you are
guilty by association of me so cute by
association so how do we use it here so
in this in this case what that just
means is good files likely to be
connected aquifer a good machine by file
likely we found on their machine right
so actually that's quite intuitive that
you think about it and in many of you is
called homophily and more technically
you can represent it as a two by two
matrix right so the rows are file good
or bad and machine a good or bad so here
this these are not actual value that are
used in the algorithm but is that gives
you an idea so it's a high value for the
diagonal entries are in saying good file
very likely or have a strong string of
association with a good machine low
strings of association with that machine
so that's a key idea that we were used
to kind of propagate information so how
do we exactly do did propagation so with
there's an algorithm called our belief
propagation is a very powerful inference
algorithm that's used in many domains
yes evidence for empirical intuition
guilt by association so the short answer
is yes
so the extract value is now learned from
the real data that Samantha has so
that's why it's not like this but is in
current think I'm similar kind of
relevant relevant decrease in the order
so I have like one short sentence it
talked about the size of the real data
okay so we used to give Association
concept and we use the absolute believed
publication act with them to do the
actual propagation of normally
information to the unknown information
and it's an algorithm used in many
domains solving many of the hard
problems actually a lot of them are the
three of the art performance so it's bpp
he's given us eight about performance
like in erica reading curved
if you're familiar with that the one of
the best era Kurylenko is based on Billy
publication so here we adapt it to help
with malware detection so instead of
going into the details about how the
algorithm where I'm going to do a really
short example of how it works on a toy
graph so you can think of this as a
dramatically scaled-down version of the
polonium graph of 37-billion edge graph
here we only have four files and three
machines and the goal here is to figure
out the reputation of file two and file
three which are currently 0.5 that means
unknown we don't always good or not and
we already know some information as in
the real case that some files is good
like file ones good file for is bad so
close to one is likely good closest year
is likely bad and similarly we have an
estimate of the machines current
reputation whether is this one is 0.6 so
slightly good point in 5 for files like
the bet and and and then it's even worse
ok so how do we do the propagation so
the go is here to figure out these two
files reputation from all on from the
rest so belief propagation there's a
reason for it to be called belief
propagation because they propagate
things so in the actual algorithm a
tried will propagate there's no
information it can start from either
side from the machine or fast so here we
say start from the machine so what it
does is that each machine will send a
message to the file that is connected to
so basically to say to tell the file was
opinion about it so for example machine
a for this message it will be telling
file to that hey you are probably good
because I'm good why is it so because we
are using the homophily
concept right the idea so the things act
similar will be connected so that means
machine a is slightly good so it'll be
telling I'll to of that well you have
probably also good similarly machine C
would be telling file free that you're
probably bad because I'm that right so
that is what each message is about and
then each file would then collect all
the incoming messages aggregate them and
to update
approximate reputation score so that
means file - this is the aggregated
values 0.58 so slightly better now for
ten point five so that's a current
estimate so it's by aggregating the two
incoming messages right so that's one
way of propagation and as you imagine
it's an iterative process so it would go
the other way around
so once the file has a updated
repetition it was go back to update the
the machines reputation right so similar
idea similar things so now you have a
better estimate of the of the Machine
reputation so you can iterating this
until the algorithm converges meaning
these until these values do not change
anymore
so that's the theoretical things but I
will quickly mentioned in a few slides
that that with a lot of time we don't
really need to do it two conversions so
in case you're really interested in the
details of the algorithm here the all
the equations that you need to know to
implement this really scalable algorithm
the only two equations so instead of
going through the symbol by symbol I'm
going to show you what they really mean
intuitively so by mapping it to the
example that you already saw so the one
equation tells you how to compute a
belief of all the reputation so meaning
if I want to compute a file reputation
for file 3 what I really need is my
incoming opinions what my neighbor tells
and there me and then also my prior
belief what I knew beforehand even
without doing anything so you combine
all these actually is a multiplication
and that you'll be able to get the
estimate so that's what you get for one
equation and then for the second
equation as you expect so it tells you
how to compute an opinion so this is the
opinion for neighbor so he's telling you
that what you need is just your current
estimate for your application so this
whole thing and then you apply the
transformation technically is called
edge potential so this is also the cube
by Association matrix that we saw
previously so that means if this is good
then the opinion would be a positive
opinion sending to the neighbor right so
that means you know how to compute a
opinion you know how to aggregate
computer opinions then you can
computer reputation score so that's all
the details and so we evaluate this
method unreal
now data that's about millions of ground
truth data so now I'm gonna known that
combined and we used two standard
10-fold cross-validation machinery so
basically that means that we divide the
data into ten parts using nine part to
set a prior or training and using the
remaining one part for testing
so this Treasury how well polonium does
so x-axis is false positive rate meaning
how many good file wrongly label aspects
so that means ideally we want it to be
close to zero we don't want any false
alarm right and then the y-axis is the
true positive rate how many good file
correctly identify as how many better I
correctly identifies better so that
means we want all that file to be
correctly identified so the ideal point
will be up here so pulling this about
85% true positive rate and 1% for Salaam
rate so you say well 1% is still pretty
high that mean one out of hundred is
wrong so here this percentage is
actually considering each application as
only counted one so meaning if they
Microsoft Word Exe is count that's wrong
then in in the real world it would be
affecting millions of people but we
don't really take into account that
actual number we only count as one so
which we each application as a single
separate entity pan we doing take into
account how many times that our files a
file appear on this machine then this
numbers become significantly lower
because most of us handle false alarm
happen for the files that Samantha
doesn't know that much about so meaning
so even though if I only appear on say
ten machines well not much you can do
you only only appear in ten machines
right so that means in real world one
percent is actually point zero zero zero
zero zero resume something so it's
really alone and the other thing is that
after integrating this method into
semantics existing frameworks is able to
boost those existing methods by 10
percent absolute point in terms of
performance so meaning that's a very
significant increase because imagine you
have an existing techniques that doing
90 percent accuracy now it does 100
accuracy so there's an absolute
percentage increase so it's very
significant increasing so after looking
at how well invest we have to look at
how where we scales were the data so
this experiment was done on a single
machine so not using clusters so do they
they are using clusters with many
machines so it's much faster so even
with just one machine running over 37
billion I just accept fix about three
hours to do it and it scales linearly in
the number of edges in the graph so it's
pretty good and a little bit details and
for those of you are working with large
data set so how do we actually make it
work on 37 billion edge so one trick we
did is we do it what we call early
termination so it's related to kind of
iterative nature of the algorithm so
meaning we don't really need to run the
algorithm two conversions because all we
care in the end is where there is good
or bad so as long as above a certain
threshold and stay there that is good we
don't care that much about the exact
value so early termination faster
running time second thing is it's due to
the nature of the algorithm we don't
really need random access to the edges
so that mean we can keep all the edges
on the graph on file and we do
sequential scan in each iteration so
hard days is good very good for
sequential scan bad for random accidents
we don't need random access we can keep
the edge on the ground on disk and the
third thing is even more a detail level
is that we can actually cut down the
computation in half so in the previous
tour example you saw I chose to start my
publication from machine and then file
machine and file machine that's actually
an other independent path that start
with file to machine file machine file
machine so they actually two paths going
on in each iteration that would
eventually give you the same thing so
that means you can remove one part and
make the computation twice as fast and
so with the experiment on single machine
with that we also look at how well it
was scale when we have multiple machines
so we we had to do implementation of the
publication and this trash shows the the
scale up to comparing to the baseline
a25 machine
so it's roughly linear so if anyone of
you have work at least a parallel system
you would know that it's really hard to
actually choose linear scalability so
anything close like this is really good
so for this experiment we did on the
yahoo m45 clusters has about 500
machines so that is Polonia so how do we
use it how to analyze an analyst may
imagine using so you can think of it I
said one way of routing people's
attention or NS attention so there might
be certain files that are getting really
lethargic and really popular but maybe
the analyst doesn't know about it yet so
those are potentially important thing
because that means that particular
malware is spreading right so if you can
you smell polonium to quickly identify
those files computer reputation instant
or relying a signature then you can
suggest those to analysts as their
starting point for analysis so that's
one example and then there's a second
very quick example is another way for
you have people identified what are the
suspicious things in network
specifically in the online auction such
as eBay so it's the one of the very
first data mining project that that got
me hooked on to data mining so as it's
still a very exciting project and
because the problem is still very
important so here we're trying to find
out who are the bad guys on eBay so
people who take your money and don't
really give you their good so who in the
audience have used eBay okay very good
I should have asked the reverse who have
not anyway so it's still a important
problem auction fraud was the number
three online crime in 2010 I don't have
to latest figure and so how do we how do
we find a bad guy so one way to think
about it or the way that I wanted to
look at it instead of treating these
people as an individual person persons
look at it in as a network of people so
each node in the network would be a
buyer or seller and actually mean a
transaction so among this network room
guys it's really hard to find out but a
lot of menu they can go in through
forums I fought rapport and so on and is
able to figure out that what the first
of all bad guys are really smart so they
will try to fabricate this reputation
score on eBay so Rachel it's user on
eBay you will have a little number that
says how many possible reputation or how
many fosters feedback that that that the
user has collected so first we're really
good at fabricating this number and the
specific way that they did it is that
they create two types of identities one
we one type we call the frost rate
identity and at the other type the
accomplice identity so all these
identities may or may not actually be
controlled by the same real person but
these two types are serve very different
purposes so rostered are the identities
who eventually trade with the victim of
the fraud victim and that compasses our
identities they act pretty much like no
honest people so they were trained with
honest people if you just look at the
transaction history you can tell
anything we are happening but then
occasionally I can accomplish with Trey
with a foster for some really expensive
thing like LCD TV laptop computer all
those super expensive things so the
reason they do it is they want to make
this particular transaction looks really
trustworthy and carry a lot of heavy
weight right because if now you want to
trade this potential the this person and
you see that from his feedback history
that is pay on time he has pays on time
for the really expensive items and so on
well then you were thinking that this is
a trustworthy person so this is a way
that that would discover about how they
were fabricating the kind of
architecture that they used to fabricate
these reputation so what that also means
is that the testing these kind of fraud
becomes trying to identify this
particular structure from the network
right in particular this structure is
what we call nearby part I core so it's
bipartite because we have two types of
nose as a core because there's a graph
in the whole graph of transaction and
it's near because they're actually some
missing edges for example this one is
not connected to all five but only two
for them
so how do we detect it so at that time
there was no known algorithm to do it so
we try a whole bunch of had with them
and in the end we found that belief
operation work out really well so in
this case we are not only using
homophily but we're also using cancer
awfully so Heather awfully means similar
things as an actually not likely to be
connected so if you you show it in like
a three by three matrix then that will
be clear so what that means is that
froster are not likely to connect it
frustrate it's likely to connect to
accomplices so more saturate that means
more likely so this is for the
heavyweight transaction that refugees
talk about so very likely to connect two
accomplices not likely to connect to
honest people until the very end when
they're ready to defraud them so
similarly a compass likely to connect
froster and not likely to accomplices
likely to connect to honest people
because they want to act like honest
people
similarly for honest people so what that
means is this three by three matrix X X
is exactly describing this nearby
particle pattern that we want to detect
so this becomes the input through the
algorithm and then applying out real
data with over eight an 800,000
transaction over sixty six from sixty
six thousand users where Buddhists
bought these real confirmed froster so
the retinas are the real confirm
phosphor that we pull from news forums
and so on and what's even better is that
we are able to find all the accomplices
and then they are the collaborating
foster so these are real cases they were
able to find and so this is what we
received quite a bit of publicity and
attention including eBay so they invited
me to the campus to give a talk and also
appear on these news outlet and
importantly again the attention of a
semantic so that's how they invited me
to work on the polonium project so they
thought well if you work for eBay
probably you work for us so yes they're
there right so it worked for for them as
well yes excuse so how did you figure
out the potential was based on
well how do we figure out that 3x3
matrix thing so we did not have enough
data to really learn the whole matrix so
there's a little bit of intuition plus a
little bit from the data because the
actual number of of cases they were able
to find is under 100 and 100 known
foster so we're not able to learn from
just that so it's a little bit intuition
- yeah right so and then there's
something I forgot to make sure so
whenever you are trying to battle bad
things the bad guys would come to you so
they were trying to contact you in this
case they contact us as Belgian police
they'll say hey so we're really
interested in your work can you send us
your source code or yeah so of course no
yes yeah so for network we also
developed a user interface to help you
to understand what's happening actually
robust to things like that right I'm a
contributor Leicester gaming for this
you're using it wouldn't be if you'd
given the source typically arms raised
right so when you have when you find out
what the bad guys do you have a
detection method then they would come
over a new thing probably so they could
actually read out paper and they figure
out all the parameters but they ask for
it a sauce go so yeah so that good
reason to ignore them so they should
read the paper yes and cite me
yeah so we had a UI and this purely
presentation so meaning we only show the
people what the algorithm is detected it
sometime you make mistakes right
and there's no way to for the user to
correct a mistake or incorporate their
feedback so that bring me to the second
part of my talk exactly for the same
reason that well algorithms are great
they can go through a lot of data very
quickly but they they are their
weaknesses right they don't incorporate
user feedback easily it is kind of like
a one-shot approach you run it and then
you get your result so in other words it
doesn't really have a user
I don't explore what are the potential
other patterns that I may want to look
at what the things that we want to look
at next so the Apolo system is a system
that kind of in to fill in this gap so
basically add the user into the data
mining process and work with the
algorithm to interactively explore a
network so a polar is published at chi
2011 I Chi is a top human-computer
interaction conference and it combines
machine learning and visualization to
help people do to exploration and
specific problem that I try to tackle is
to help you Pro find more relevant nodes
in a network so meaning if you're
interested in tune of who knows in the
network what are the other notes that
you might also be interested in looking
at so here's a concrete example looking
at a citation network so each note would
be a paper and an edge would be a
citation so suppose or imagine you are a
grad student and first-year grad student
your advisors say well you are
interesting xgi and data mining so
here's to pay per degree to start
reading HDI paper data mining paper okay
after reading it go figure out what
other paper you might want to read so
yes how would you do that so intuitively
you will imagine papers that are close
to your current interest will be what
you are interested in so close here
meaning the papers that are citing your
paper or being cited your paper and
actually that match a lot of the cases
that what people are actually doing
right so how would you find a paper you
do a Google Scholar or you maybe you
will read this paper and see what this
paper
cited so that means you go to its
neighbors right and similarly when
you're reading this paper you may say oh
what other paper may I want to let look
at so look at it related work what has
decided so you go to this so that means
papers that close or closely connected
like maybe through many paths or
actually directly linked to your current
interest might be more relevant further
away less so so what they also means is
actually we can use cuba association
right and in this case is a very
difference in area of very different use
we're using it to explore data instead
of doing classification may where
detection so I'm going to show you a
quick demo about how Apollo works and
specifically this enero is on helping
the user or camping aggressor you know
to understand all the map out of the
sense making literature so sense making
is as a field in an ex-gi
so it study how people make sense of
information so as you expect the overlap
many research area so what we're showing
you here is kind of the outcome that we
want to see after the whole scenario so
the user i'm imagine your user would be
starting with one paper that's called
the cost structure of sense-making
same information you can see here down
here title authors and so on so this
data is citation data does call from
google scholar so anything can get from
google scholar you can find it here so
no is a paper and actual best citation
it's directed because you can't
direction in the citation one papers
citing the other right and the size no
size is the number of citation related
with the number citation that I pick
were has larger the size more times is
cited
so in this data set we have about eighty
thousand papers caught on Google and 150
thousand citations and this is kind of
what we want to get out up in the end so
in here we identified our three research
area collaboration search information
management and information visualization
and also we're able to find out what are
some good example papers could keep a
preset that particularly relevant for
the three areas so this is a user
interface of a polo and the
getting when they're only one my
starting paper at the cost of Jeff
sense-making
we will show you on the right the papers
that either directly cited it or linked
to it or being site about it so on the
right when you click on it on the paper
and they are sorted by citation account
currently so for this scenario I'm
cheating a little bit here because I
already know what all those papers are
about so and well thing over like
actually looking at the paper abstract
and so on so I'll just focus on the
paper title so my first thing I would do
is I go to the list and I say well so
are there any general paper area that I
may be able to find just looking at a
title so there is that's one pretty
general thing called information
visualization and then there's another
one that title is called search together
so it's about search so why not I create
you oops or I put them into two bin no
one we called it search and then the
other I call it involve bits right so
now that to two groups so what there's
two things that happen one is that
automatically assigning a color to them
and the second thing is these two papers
actually become the exemplar papers
after two groups so remember in the toy
example that I show you
so these two papers now become kind of
source or your current note of interest
right and by doing that then you can use
the algorithm to infer what other notes
are relevant to those two so that's
exactly what we're doing next
so the since I I have an example for the
Search Group then I can ask a polo to
the aunt ten other papers at that if
things are relevant so color saturation
here means relevant so more saturated
more relevant so it's already ordered by
by that and quickly skimming through the
title I can see the first one is
relevant is about search and the second
one also is about search Co search
collaborative search so pretty good and
I think that's good enough for now
very quickly I already found some
relevant papers to read and now I go
back to my starting paper and say oh why
don't I look at some papers that
directly linked to it
right and here are the papers by default
a sorted by citation count so all the
size of the other paper but since I have
the two groups created so I say why
don't I sort them by how likely that
polo things belong to involve this so
that can help you quickly identify
relevant paper to involvement so if I
could look at just the title then I see
the first one is about information
visualization and and the third and the
second and third also so now you can see
a pretty obvious change in the color
saturation so some of the papers to
become more saturated so actually that's
a good thing because since color
saturation map to the relevance that
Apolo infer so more more saturated now
that means the algorithm also think
these are more relevant to the
successful scientists in that I'm please
return that I pro baseball with certain
self-citations strategies as well find
diverse papers as opposed to cleats of
no bodywork by a successful group right
so the question is like whether we can
we can find diverse group diverse paper
so by by construction I think it would
be pretty hard like without modification
because we here we're only based on the
length structure right so only a
citation right yes so there are data
mining machinery and techniques which
basically find exactly and solve the
problem is to find a diversity of how to
you find good in the recommendation but
not kind of homogeneous to homogeneous
yes right so and if I keep doing this
and then I can probably find another new
area personal information management
then I can do the same thing right I can
create a new group and so on and then
find other relevant paper
so I would love to extend this more to
support all those other operations that
are very important
yeah but this is how it works it's very
simple and so usually specify exemplars
and then the algorithm helps your user
find out what other things they might be
interested in so you may ask so why do
we use believe publication but not other
algorithm there seem to be many other
things that you might use yeah so
riffing on just question the same stuff
I find highly central nodes in the graph
when often you're what you care about
given a certain literature search for
imagine you're doing is something that's
explicitly moment that you might have
missed I feel like that would be another
really interesting space to look at
given what I know these these near
misses for less central there may be
recent work or outside of the citation
graph that yes yes definitely so so
finding out what you're missing is that
definitely very very important area so
we have been looking at that way we
don't have a paper yet but you got you
know how to do it then yeah we should
collaborate yes yeah so that may as you
mentioned there are a lot of things that
we can do like if we're able to bring in
the algorithm and also the interface so
the particular algorithm that will use a
belief propagation so you may ask why
why why would use it another thing so
well one major reason is that already
support a lot of desirable sense-making
features are like how when when people
naturally interact what data what do we
want to do so we found that they were
all the time based on literature all
right also observations who that they
will create multiple groups or it's
believed publication directly support me
do you support multiple examples for
each group also immediately support and
then I did not show it here but they
actually also support negative examples
meaning if there are papers that you
don't think belong a group or you don't
think belong to any group you can
specify two so positive and negative
example and also as fast so as you saw
previously in the demo that is running
in the background in real time and so
we're first to use it for glee
publication so we also look at how this
algorithm compared to all the other
algorithm that generally fall under
we call diffusion type of algorithm like
initially I there's a spreading
activation in data mining that's random
walk where we start or personalized
paycheck so we look at how these compare
and in our PK DD a data mining
confidence paper we look at how they can
play exactly and we found that but this
publication is very flexible so it can
capture a lot of things that other
algorithm can do like random walk we
start plus more
so not homophily but also had to roughly
and so on so that's the reason we picked
them using we have prorogation for large
networks it's not bipartite so the
question is have we have you used the
publication on other network and not
bipartite yes my experience he has
gorgeous problems when it comes to large
dance crumbs yes yes so so the thing is
that billy public is there's no
theoretical guarantee that it would
converge so yeah so we haven't really
solved that problem so the way they
tried it on different real world data
they seem to work pretty well yeah when
it doesn't you can you can purchase but
the worst problem is that you have this
effect pattern there so just another one
right so if you can't deliver you so
there are cases where people have found
in applying it on real world data where
the when the the the value do not
converge he might actually fluctuate
between two so I think we're fortunate
that maybe due to the nature of data and
we haven't seen that but yes that it
could happen it could happen so it's a
quick recap of Paulo's contribution so
the first thing is that exactly a very
intuitive way for people to work with
the machine so one of the a polar user
actually comment on that he's doing
things that he would do anyways and now
there's this add the benefit of getting
these suggestion automatic suggestion
and while they're doing doing these
categories a sensation and the second
thing is that the Apollo how each user
generate a very personalized landscape
update of the graph so
meaning even with the same citation
network data depending on your examples
that you give to it you are able to
generate these different different
grouping and different suggestions and
that's very useful in many many cases
because imagine you're writing two
papers you might be looking at the same
set of relating work but you were
probably right about them very
differently you organize them
differently also so the meaning same
data set different interpretation
different suggestions so a poll started
back in 2009 so again you would know
that I have my name in it Apollo with
one L so it's literally my baby that was
born in 2009 and this is very first
interface that we had so is now I can
say it's a terrible interface because is
just one box for each group and then the
bowl of things are the suggestions and
the rest are the only thing I'll
examples and rest is suggestions so it
doesn't really tell their user anything
about the connection between the items
within a group or across groups so this
was disastrous so that prompted us to
add in the visualization component the
graph initialization component so now
people are is able to understand their
suggestion a lot better and we also
found something that also something
they're really interesting is that
people don't really use the list that
much anymore they only use it when they
want to compare things so it can promise
to remove the list completely so that we
have more space for people to work on
the visualization and we added the
ranking place feature which you saw
where we dynamically change the ordering
of the items right in the visualization
so that when they need it then they can
do it but otherwise they can focus on
the the ground so we did a user study to
evaluate a polar the data that the
participant uses is that a citation
Network where we are you already saw and
the task for the participant is to find
related work for two sections of a
survey paper that we gave them so this
is the actual paper that we gave them
it's called past present and future of
user interface software tools so is
there is a survey all these different
areas of UI design
tools software tools and so we'll pick
to section out of it and then with this
attitude this specific section one is
called model-based generation of user
interface the others repre to typing of
repetative typing - so model-based
generation meaning can you automatically
generate a user interface based on a
model that computer scientists can
create so and then you automatically
boom yeah that you are so there are a
lot of research on that and then the
second area section is what are the
tools that can help people quickly build
user interface so these are two sections
that we gave the participant and their
task was that me to find related work
for each of them basically to update
this paper this was published in around
1990 so we asked them to say what find
new papers are published in the next ten
years so it was a between subject study
so meaning we have two conditions and
each participant only use one software
to do the same same task so there are
twelve participants and six in each
condition using a polo or Google Scholar
so they are grad students or research
staff who have computer science
background but they don't know that much
about user interface research so these
are the two sections we gave them right
so the each of them work for each
section though if I know the related
paper so we're pulling all together all
these paper wiki gave these papers to
well to expert judges who are professors
actually well two of the three offers of
that paper to rate those papers at the
participant as well so they would give a
score of one ifs relevant zero is not
relevant so which beeping as a maximum
score of two and minimum score zero so
this is a result
so in short a polar winds influence
better and for the for the model based
case is only slightly better the reason
is model Bayes is a very specific thing
model-based generation of UI is very
specific things and people can just type
model base in the in Google Scholar and
then they automatically find a lot of
relevant paper while for the prototyping
cases it's a different story because
prototyping is a very general concept
that up here in many domains like design
in engineering and so on so in this case
I pulled a lot better and on FAQ so this
didn't is statistically significant
so recap now because it's already very
well all right
it seems really this is one of those
redevelopment you don't have keywords
and Google Scholar works really well
that you can have keywords yes you can
think of it that way that says that for
once so much you've got no difference in
for another search your viewer of Howell
is better
yeah so why I think we need more
convincing search right because the user
can't do whatever they want with Google
Scholar relevant paper so anything they
think irrelevant so that is they
actually doing different the searching
for different thing they don't even know
what they aren't going to find we don't
know what they're going to find either
so so the argument that I would make is
that for this link based approach el
pollo is doing is good to go from the
one paper to the other cut directly
linked like through the through the
network we think that's better than just
using keyword search because we actually
know how things are kind of grouped or
like in proximity to each other so
that's why we think that that that's
better than Google Scholar so that also
means you are doing a more local kind of
search it feels like it would not be
nice substantive discussion and things
like that didn't they and they in the
paper so yes and I would be happy to
talk to you more about it thank you
yeah so now quick recap for the poll oh
yeah how did he choose fish edges to
highlight in which seems like yeah the
the edges that are directly connected to
what I have selected so this is just
official artifact it's not doing
anything do you have any data on the
relative speeds of the two systems or
like for people faster and Apollo than a
Google Scholar I yes I do I do think
that didn't pay for it
to look at like what's to every time
that people completed so sort of the is
that we do cap all the time that they
spent on the whole chat I think that
given that 20 minutes to find all these
papers so now Paul is contributing to
several a project including the darpur
Adams projects for Adam stand for
anomaly detection at multiple scales so
the the goal of the project stride to
detect these insider threats so you
remember a few years back there was that
a shooter in a military base where a
psychiatrist turned violent into shooter
and so that's kind of the the insider
threat that some parts trying to deflect
so this is say well can we detect other
previously good a person suddenly turn
turned bad and for this project
Apollo is now contributing as a major
visualization component to help the
analyst better understand what's
detected so that's a polar say ii was
combining machine learning and
visualization to help people explore a
large ground so the final part is about
kind of vision or the things that I'm
excited about the line of research I
think are really exciting and so big
data as you know it's not the future
because we are already there so it's
happening right now and we're having all
these large amount data that over
many domains and I believe that
combining data mining a human computer
action is a very viable way of
approaching this challenge and
specifically if we can create this new
class of hybrid tools that combine the
best of both worlds then we can really
take the expertise and intuition of
people and also scalability of machines
to deal with the challenge so here are
some of the example things I'd like to
work on the three things I'd like to
focus on the first thing is what I call
enabling interactive data analytics so
one challenge that you may see you when
you're working on this large-scale data
mining machine learning algorithm so the
people will tell you that we have really
scalable techniques but they don't
really tell you that
you snooze away for hours or even days
to get your a result work on it wait so
what doesn't be nice we were able to
look at the any like you can just a
computation we stuff from a subset of
the data and then let the user to tell
the algorithm that hey so what you show
me so far there's a huge chunk that our
own really care about there's a little
that I really do care about so focus
your remaining focus the remaining
computation on that part then it can
dramatically speed things out right so
that's one thing kind of a high-level
idea Isetta that want to pursue and
specifically we already started on that
and through using a really scalable
algorithm in the backend did this graph
mining or mining of a large graph and
then using a pole as a front-end for
people to interact with the that the
data or the subset of the data and then
give feedback to the algorithm so what
this package the package is graph mining
package one then so we were super award
in the open source world challenge in
2011 and the whole work is submitted as
a a signal demo in 2012 and the second
error is of course to go beyond just
graph data to many more data types
applications and domains so here's one
example work that I'm doing working on
right now is to develop an interactive
visualization to help people understand
results um topic models so
documents
watch document collections the documents
here represented as the orange dot and
then the topics to infer from these
documents the blue rectangle or the
three squares so how close a document is
as to a topic is basically the string or
they how likely that the document
belonged to that topic so by allowing
user to move these topics around they
can actually do these ad hoc
classification so I say you group like
some topics in one and then the other
topics in two so immediately you get
these lined of for classification
actually think you said I close to those
two and they are like more likely to be
long terms too so so allowing people to
play with these interactive
visualization they can actually help
them build a model about a data and the
first thing is what I call the
collaborated big data analysis so the
work that I've shown you today they as
you may notice they actually were like a
single person and analytics so they're
designed for basically one person it's
not really combining expertise from
multiple people and as you imagine when
we deal with these real-world complex
data you need more than one person to
work on the analysis and these people
may be co-located they may be
distributed live in location they may
even be using different devices some may
be using desktop one might be using a
tablet or maybe even a film if they're
doing like some kinda meter job of of
the cloud so how do we combine the input
from all these different people or maybe
and say to people working on the same
problem but they have a different mental
map or a landscape that they created
from the data how do we combine all
these things so that's a very exciting
area that I think can really use a lot
more research into and so those are the
three things that I'm interested in
interactive big data analytics more
application domains and also the
collaborative aspects and with that I'd
like to stop here for today and
because I like to say my hope is Jeff
and also many of you come here and also
my collaborators industry government and
CMU at Georgia Tech thank you very much
for a few questions so I'm curious about
this are a variety of things of big data
so if you think about now what will be
the current make more interesting work
that has been done so collaborative yeah
what was the most exciting has not been
done so I'm very new to in this area so
I don't know whether it has or has not
been done
five years ago before the building was
built we're an adult with medical
applications to try to learn trying to
extract information on the large patient
database I'm guessing that's probably a
huge potential optimization that where
the nodes where each node might be a
patient record I'm trying to find
similar patients and disease clones are
just letting the data speak for
themselves to try and identify this
village yes a big thing and I think one
one challenge I would say is when you
combine expertise from actually
different domains knowledge from
different domains I'm not just talking
about I and all data mining analysts but
actually there may Express from like I
have care all that actually meant
medical doctors and with the domain
expert in data mining all these things
so they have very different view even
with the same data they see things
differently so how do you combine that I
think that's a super challenging but
very important area I don't think that's
enough work done in that in that area so
that could answer part of your question
and you should always talk to jumpin
yeah good more yes something else is
that it finds a way to take some fairly
complex concepts and make them scribble
within the user interface in a way that
machine learning and interactive machine
learning often struggles to make this
effort wall wondering if there was some
underlying heuristic or approach that
you use in your work or moving forward
that we could apply that you that you
think would be profitable in that kind
of direction yes so that's actually kind
of the line of research ethics I'd like
to pursue is to identify are there
classes of machinery and data mining
algorithm that are more amenable to
being used in interactive application
and what are they and what are their
characteristics because there are a
certain kind of algorithms that are
really hard kind of like black boxes
where you don't really know how
the map or they may not even have
parameters but if they do they might be
very hard to map to like a user
interface or how to service it in the
polar work our mapping building
application to actually enter into
action so user when they put something
in the group you're actually changing
the underlying probability or
probability out there so there are
definitely a certain kind of algorithm
they're more easy to work with more easy
to surface things and I don't think
again I don't think that's enough work
to to in that area yet but it's very
very important I think people are
starting to look at it in terms of
heuristics I think based on there's a
peak EDD paper that I briefly mentioned
we're curious I with all these different
air with them and try to identify what
are the key common commonality among all
those and we busily start from those and
picking out the the right algorithm is
often very hard so I don't have like a
magic formula to say oh so always try
this first so watch always try that
first so you do need to understand a
little bit about the algorithm and your
problem yeah
you